PROFESSOR: Let us consider the
anharmonic oscillator, which
means that you're taking the
unperturbed Hamiltonian to be
the harmonic oscillator.
And now, you want to
add an extra term that
will make this anharmonic.
Anharmonic reflects the fact
that the perturbations are
oscillations of the system
are not exactly harmonic.
And in the harmonic oscillator,
the energy difference
between levels is
always the same.
That's a beautiful property
of the harmonic oscillator.
That stops happening in
an anharmonic oscillator.
The energy differences can vary.
So the things, if you have
a transition from one level,
first level to the ground state,
or second level to the ground
state, one is not the
harmonic of the other
because they're not exactly
twice as big as each other.
So let's try to add an x to
the 4th perturbation, which
is intuitively very clear.
You have a potential.
And you're adding
now an extra piece
that behaves like x to the 4th.
And it's going to make this
potential blow up faster.
Now, in order to
get the units right,
we need the length scale.
There's a length scale d
in the harmonic oscillator.
We're going to use it.
One way to derive
that length scale is
to recall from units that p,
a momentum, has units of h
divided by length.
So b squared has units of
h squared over d squared.
There's an m.
So that's an energy.
And this is an energy too.
So we can set it equal to
m omega squared d squared.
From where we get, for
example, as 1 over d to the 4th
is equal to m squared omega
squared over h squared.
And d squared is equal
to h over m omega.
So that's a length
scale, something
with units of length in
the harmonic oscillator.
So if we want to add
the perturbation that
is x to the 4th, we'll
add a lambda delta
H that is going to
be a lambda, which
is unit freedom, something
that has units of energy.
So you can put h bar
mega has units of energy.
And then you can
put the operator x
to the 4th divided
by d to the 4th.
It's a perturbation
with units of energy.
This is good.
So there's a couple of
ways of thinking of it.
You may remember that in
the harmonic oscillator
x, the operator x, was given
by the square root of h
over 2m omega, a plus a dagger.
So this is d times a plus a
dagger over square root of 2.
So this perturbation lambda
delta H is equal to lambda.
H bar omega would be here.
H bar omega.
Now x/d is this a plus a dagger
divided by square root of 2.
So you have a 4a plus
a dagger to the 4th.
So that's lambda delta H.
That's your perturbation.
So what do we want to do
with this perturbation?
It's a nice perturbation.
We want to compute
the corrections
to the energy,
corrections to the states,
and see how they go.
We can do that easily.
Let's compute first that
corrections to the ground state
energy.
These are calculations
that are not difficult,
but they take some care.
As any calculation,
it's based on just
getting a lot of numbers right.
So what is the ground
state energy correction?
So we had a series of
formulas that I just erased.
But this index k0
for our state, we
can think of k as being the
eigenvalue of the number
operator.
So we'll get n.
And remember in the
harmonic oscillator,
we label states by 0, 1, 2, 3.
And that's the eigenvalue
of the number operator
in the harmonic oscillator.
So the ground state energy
would correspond to 0,
has a first order
correction that
would be given by the
unperturbed ground state
and delta H 0.
So what is that?
Delta H is h omega over 4.
And we have 0 a plus
a dagger to the 4th 0.
Easy enough.
That's what we have to do.
Now, the evaluation
of that matrix element
is a simple exercise,
the kind of things
you've been doing before.
You have to expand and just
use the aa dagger computation
relation that this aa
dagger is equal to 1.
You said repeatedly
a kills the vacuum.
a dagger kills the other
vacuum on the left.
Please do it.
If you feel you're
out of practice,
the answer is the number 3 here.
So e01 is equal to
3/4 h bar omega.
So how does that
tell you anything?
Well, better use
the full formula.
So e0 of lambda is supposed to
be equal to the ground state
energy unperturbed,
which was h omega over 2
plus lambda times the first
order correction, which
is 3/4 h bar omega plus
order lambda squared.
So e0 of lambda
is h omega over 2,
1 plus 3/2 lambda plus
order lambda squared.
That's what we got.
And that makes nice sense.
Your ground state energy you
knew used to be h omega over 2.
If you introduce
this perturbation,
you don't expect it
to jump abruptly.
It's going to grow
up with the lambda
to the 4th term with the
x to the 4th term into 3/2
lambda here, a small correction.
So far, so good.
What takes a bit more work
is doing a higher order
correction.
So let's do the
next one as well.
So for this second order
correction, we have a formula.
And let's see what it tells us.
It tells us that the second
order correction to the energy
is minus the sum over all states
that are not the ground states.
So it's k different from 0.
That's good enough.
Delta H 0k squared
over Ek0 minus e00.
So potentially, it's
an infinite sum.
And that's the kind of thing
that is sometimes difficult.
In many examples, you
have infinite sums.
Sometimes you can
do an approximation,
say a few terms is
all you need to do.
But in this case,
happily, it's not
going to be an infinite sum.
So what do we have?
Delta H0k is what we
need to calculate.
The energy differences, we know.
These are the unperturbed
harmonic oscillator energy
differences.
What we need is this object,
which is h bar omega over 4.
Remember, what is delta H there
in that box formula there.
And we have 0 a plus a
dagger to the 4th K, where
K is a state with number K.
If you wish, you could
say K is a dagger
to the K over square root of K
factorial acting on the ground
state.
But sometimes you
don't need that.
You actually don't need
to put the value of K.
So our challenge here is to
see which values of K exist.
For that, you can
think of this part
of the term, the a plus a
dagger to the 4th acting
on the vacuum.
This is like, in
a sense, this term
is nothing else but in saying
what happens to the wave
function when you
multiply it by x to the 4,
to the ground state
wave function.
That's physically what
you're doing here.
You're multiplying an x to
the 4th times the ground
state wave function.
So it should give you
an even wave function.
So you would expect that x
to the 4th multiplied by 5 0
should be proportional to 5
0, but maybe 5 2 and 5 4th.
Should not have the odd ones
because this function is not
odd.
It's even.
So as you express x to the 4th
5 0 in terms of the other ones,
it should be that.
So indeed, again, I ask you
to do a little computation.
If you do 0 a plus a dagger
to the 4th, this is equal to--
you can show.
It gives you 4 factorial
square root the state 4
plus 6 square root of
2 times the state 2
plus 3 times times
the ground state.
OK.
So we have that look
let's continue therefore.
Given that [INAUDIBLE] has
given us three states--
one proportional to the
vacuum, one proportional
to the state with occupation
number 2, and one with a state
of occupation number four--
the values of k
that are relevant,
since k is different
from 0, are only 2 and 4.
0 doesn't matter.
And only 2 and 4
can couple here.
So what do we get?
Delta H0 4 would be, from
this formula, h omega
over 4 times this inner
product when k is equal to 4.
So you get here square
root of 4 factorial,
which is h omega over 2
times square root of 6.
Delta H02 is equal
to h omega over 4.
And the overlap of
this state with 2,
which is 6 square root of 2.
So this is h omega 3
square root of 2/2.
OK.
So that's your first step.
When you have to
compute a perturbation,
you have to compute all the
relevant matrix elements.
And you have to think
what you can get.
And only k equal 2
and 4 happen, so this
is the sum of two terms.
So the second order
correction to the energy
is minus delta H0 2
squared divided by E2 0
minus E0 0 minus delta H0 4
squared over E4 0 minus E0 0.
So what is this?
It's minus delta H0 2 squared
is h bar omega squared.
9 times 2/4.
And you divide by
this difference.
And the difference between
E2 and E0 is 2 h bar omega.
There's an h bar omega
difference every state.
So you go from E0 to
E1 to E2, two of them.
Minus delta H0 4 squared, which
is H omega squared times 6/4
over 4 h bar omega.
Well, this gives you
minus 21/8 h bar omega.
And therefore, the
energy, this is the E0 2,
so you can go back here
and write E0 lambda is
equal to H omega over 2.
1 plus 3/2 lambda.
And then the next term
that we now calculated
is 21/4 lambda squared.
Very good.
We work hard.
We have lambda squared
correction to this energy.
Now, this is not really trivial.
There's no analytic way
to solve this problem.
Nobody knows an analytic
way to solve this problem.
So this is a nice
result. It's so famous
the problem that people have
written hundreds of papers
on this.
The first people that did
a very detailed analysis
was Bender and Wu.
And they computed probably
100 terms in the series or so.
The next term turns out
to be 333/8 lambda cube.
Followed by 30,855/64 lambda
to the 4th plus ordered lambda
to 5th.
Funnily, these people also
proved that this series
has no radius of convergence.
It never converges.
It just doesn't converge at all.
You would say, oh,
what a waste of time.
No, it's an asymptotic
expansion, this series.
So it can be used.
So it's a very funny thing.
Series sometimes don't
converge so well.
And this one is a peculiarly
non-convergent series.
So what does it mean only that
it's an asymptotic expansion?
Basically, the expansion
for the factorial
that you use in statistical
mechanics all the time,
Sterling's expansion, is
an asymptotic expansion.
Quantum electro dynamics
with Feynman rules
is an asymptotic expansion.
Very few things actually
converge in physics.
That's the nature of things.
What it means is that
when you take lambda,
for example, to be 1 in 1,000,
a very small number, then
this is 1.
This will be very small.
This will still be small.
This will be small.
And eventually, the terms go
smaller, smaller, smaller,
smaller, smaller, smaller.
And eventually,
start going up again.
And if you have an
asymptotic expansion,
you're supposed to
stop adding terms
until they become the smallest.
And that will be a good
approximation to your function.
So this can be used.
You can use it.
You can do numerical
work with the states
and compare with
asymptotic expansion.
And it's a very nice thing.
Another thing is that you can
compute the first correction
to the state.
I will leave that
as an exercise.
And in the notes, you
will find the expression
of the first correction
to this state.
It's not much work
because, after all, it
involves just this kind
of matrix elements.
So it's basically using
the matrix elements
to write something else.